We're days away from the end
of Obama's presidency, which...
I don't know
if you guys are aware--
we're getting
a new president pretty soon?
-You guys don't pay attention to
the news. -(audience groaning)
But-but what's
Hussein-in-the-Membrane
got planned now that he won't be
busy pardoning turkeys 24/7?
Well, according to Billboard,
Obama made an offhand remark
to the ambassador to Sweden
-that he's still waiting for
his job at Spotify. -(laughter)
The well-known streaming service
that informs your friends
you were listening
to Papa Roach all day.
Well, Obama's quip inspired
Spotify CEO
Daniel Elk to tweet,
"Hey @BarackObama,
"I heard you were interested
in a role at Spotify.
Have you seen this one?"
And it wasn't just him
pointing at his dick,
although
that would have been hilarious.
It was actually a job listing
for President of Playlists
right here.
Ah, we're having lots of fun.
Makes you forget for
a second that
the next Secretary of Defense
is probably going
to be Waluigi.
-(laughter and groaning)
-Um, so, comedians...
Comedians, in case
the Spotify gig
doesn't work out, what's another
tech job Obama might consider
after office?
Ify.
I think he's gonna bring hope
and change
to the street fight videos
on Worldstar Hip Hop.
-HARDWICK: Yes, points. Points.
-(laughter)
-Katy.
-Um, I don't know about Obama,
but Biden's got a job moderating
the all-natural MILF subreddit.
-HARDWICK: Okay, points. Yeah.
-(laughter)
-All-natural, Flula.
-President of Tinder,
because he's used
to dealing with dicks all day.
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
Very good one. -(laughter)